all right
what's up y'all
you know doing this by myself technical
difficulties i can't even hear myself
but we're gonna do the best we can
[Music]
i can't even hear you
[Music]
can't hear the music y'all
we're not even gonna do the music i know
you guys can hear the music but i can't
hear the music i don't know what i did i
did something to my system so i couldn't
hear the music so
unfortunately no riffing with griffin
intro today i know you heard the music a
little bit i mean
it is what it is i hope you guys can
hear me but i did something to my
settings and i can't hear
i can't hear anything so it's just
you know what i mean it's just it's just
i don't know
i i really don't know what let me just
try this again just to see if i can hear
this
[Music]
no i can't i can't hear it at all so if
i can't hear it i can't do the music so
it is what it is but you know i guess we
could just see it all welcome to riffin
[Music]
all right y'all today's riffing with
griffin is brought to you by
doordash
doordash y'all doordash doordash
connects you with everything you want
whenever you whenever and however you
want it get 25 off and zero delivery
fees on your first order of 15 or more
when you download the door dash app and
enter code griffin
doordash
this episode is also brought to you by
helix sleep
helix sleep y'all big shout out today
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life find your perfect mattress at
helixsleep.com
griffin
okay we're doing it live and you know we
do it live there's all kinds of stuff i
hope you guys can hear me well you guys
hear me good there uh in the chat so
please let me know that i'm coming in
good and clear because like i said i
can't hear myself the way i normally can
hear myself so i don't know what the
hell is going on with that so i hope you
guys can hear me um
anyways it looks like i'm seeing the
monitor so it looks like you guys can
hear me good all right so today guys i'm
not even gonna hesitate
the whole episode i'm dedicating to
batman y'all dedicated to bat
batman i got my batman shirt on
it's all about batman batman all day
long
you know so
like i say i'm not going to
i'm not going to spoil the movie uh
right up front i just want to talk we
just talk a little bit about batman and
just like you know my thoughts um you
know about the thing but you know before
i even start about batman i just want to
say i had a good week i was just out in
uh brea last night thanks for everybody
that showed up to the shows there
um
and then like on the 12th is my birthday
big birthday guys i'm turning 50 on the
12th so all the jokes about me being old
and 50 and what all you know people that
make those jokes those trolls that say
that you're actually right so
uh yeah so this uh
coming out i'm gonna be 50. so make sure
you uh you know happy birthday to me
it's a big one starting my own life i
feel like i've already lived a full
lifetime now i'm starting a whole new
life because i'm getting married in june
it's like wow what am i doing right so
it's all that and make sure thanks for
subscribing sharing doing all the stuff
that you guys normally do thanks for
being here for that
um you know what i mean so thanks for
that guys uh and then you know remember
i'm always on twitch
twitch make sure you check me out on
twitch
uh
eric griffin gaming i'm always on there
daily
um so make sure you check that out make
sure you check me out on everything else
i do gender gen we're recording this
week and also check me out on king of
the sting doing a recording for that too
i know everybody's like
guys relax
i'm still doing a bunch of king and
sting episode so it is what it is man
um
anyway so let's get to it all right so
batman dude you know i i saw the movie
and we'll talk about the movie later and
i'll let you know if you haven't seen it
spoilers that'll be the time you guys
should leave
um
but
my first introduction to batman for me
as a kid was
the batman would would be
the um what do you call it the the car
the comic books so like i never
collected batman and i wasn't a big
comic book guy um but you know i i later
when i was you know i started to because
you could order the comic books so you
could like sign up for a service and
they could order comics so i started to
do that but i was more of like i liked
marvel better so i was more of like i
was getting uh spider-man and i was
getting avengers i used to love the
avengers and i would get like the marvel
team up those were my favorite um
those were my favorite uh
that was spider-man and like he would
like team up with another superhero and
that would be that that episode of the
of the
the that thing of the comic book so
that was pretty great so but batman was
just like yeah we knew who batman was
and you know i wasn't really a dc guy so
i didn't really get into like the dc
comics but um
you know it was pretty cool so like so
my real first was like the comic but the
real thing about that that really got me
with batman was the tv series with adam
west and that was they even had a move i
think they had a movie first which i
don't even remember and then they did
this tv series batman
and it was like you know it was so
cheesy and corny it you know but back
then tv it couldn't be dark it couldn't
be menacing it was just like it was fun
and campy it was the whole thing like
they were punching he would see a thing
on the screen go blam
pow skull bam but you know you kind of
got this um feeling of
you got you got a sense of what it was
about you know batman was this superhero
he was this rich guy bruce wayne and
people didn't realize that he was batman
and so you kind of got this like dual
personality thing going on and he was a
superhero and you and you had all these
great villains you know you had catwoman
you had penguin you had the riddler you
had the joker and you know it was like
they were and they were like these they
those characters were always bigger than
batman uh but and then you had robin the
boy wonder and all that so it was like
that was like your first time kind of
like being interested in it you know and
then it wasn't till
i believe
um in 1989
that
batman came to the big screen in a big
fashion
and that was with um
michael keaton as batman and jack
nicholson playing the joker
and that was the first time we kind of
saw this on the big screen and the and
it was the first time they introduced
this origin story that we've heard
at nauseam a million times about batman
that his parents were killed and then
this launched him into becoming batman
later in life but um in the batman in
1989
um
you know he kind of just
he was already batman you know what i
mean like so you didn't really get like
hey i wonder how you became batman so
they didn't want to even show all that
they just came up like well here's
batman and then you know that started a
string of movies as michael keaton as
batman and then you know from there was
batman returns in 1992.
uh
batman once again played by michael
keaton
and then it was
uh batman then
i think michael keaton only did two and
then in 1997
i believe it was
um yeah and then it was batman and robin
um
yeah it was batman and robin and then
that's when it kind of to me went off
the rails you know yeah let's see like
it was batman and robin yeah 1997 and it
was george clooney and chris o'donnell
and
and arnold schwarzenegger playing
you know the mr freeze but it still was
like
it was a sort of campy feel that batman
had right it was just it was always this
sort of like you know
there was nothing dark to it nothing
menacing it was still it was kind of for
kids but at the same time on the big
screen you're showing these images it's
like what age like is this appropriate
for so i don't know so the superhero
genre was still like super champion like
nonsensical to me you know and these
movies were just like and this is the
one where like the nipples on the thing
and you're just kind of like what is
this you know what i mean just a weird
batman movie uh batman batman and robin
uh you know then there was like uh you
know i don't know uh chubby
chubby batgirl and
it was i don't know man it just was like
a weird
those were weird batman's you know and
then like oh see i'm trying to see
they're supposed to show the batman
movies in order but they're not
showing me them in the proper order
because okay yeah yeah yeah okay so you
had batman batman returned 1992
yeah i said that one
oh you know which one i forgot i forgot
in 1995 batman forever
batman forever was um val kilmer
yeah that was the valkyr one now the val
i actually liked val kilmer as batman
um
but that one was to me was like the
first time
batman a little darkish right but it
still became campy because that's the
one that had
um
jim carrey playing the riddler and he
just was super over the top but still
the tone of the movie was still just
and that was 1995 the tone of the movie
was still that sort of campiness uh and
just over the top performances i
remember by jim carrey and um what's his
face
uh who was uh tommy lee jones like they
those two characters tommy jones playing
two-face and it was just kind of like
all right you know and
then it was batman and robin in 1997
right so that's like the batman origin
okay and then from there it went batman
begins now let me tell you something
right now
batman begins
to me
changed the superhero
genre now there was plenty of cartoons i
see people in the chat talking about
that there were a lot of cartoons there
was a lot of like
dc stories that you know and the comics
kept going and you had all these great
stories and if you're into the batman
lore and the batman like you know
whatever that stuff is you know the
batman you know if you're really into
the batman genre then you know about all
these like little secret gems that they
had out there and they were making
little cartoons and stuff but like in
terms of the movie um
how it how it
progressed
batman begins to me is one of the most
important superhero movies of our
generation it changed the genre it
changed how we look at superhero movies
it changed how
you cast superhero movies you know it
you know it became like an artsy fartsy
artistic
um genre it really did and this one was
and then this is the first time they
actually went into like here's how bruce
wayne became batman
you know and i think christian bale did
a fantastic job you know it's just sort
of like a brooding you know and really
explained it you know they explain like
the city like gotham is just the
cesspool of a city and is
riddled with crime and then because of
that crime his father was killed and he
was a boy he couldn't do anything and he
just felt powerless and he was like you
know what what am i going to do and then
you know he's just like you know he he
can't get any kind of justice and then
he decides to like disappear he realizes
like you know what i can't make any
change and then he goes off on his own
and then he realizes wow people commit
crimes for different reasons they're not
all terrible people and then he goes on
to like find the you know what's his
name razal ghoul and the and the league
of shadows and then and he learns how to
like fight and he becomes a he becomes
batman he learns the skills of fear and
all this stuff and you're just kind of
like ooh it was so gritty and you just
really got a sense of like all right
yeah this is how he became batman and
then he was like comes back and he's
super rich and so he has the an r d
department and you kind of get a sense
of like all right this is believable
that this guy can become batman so to me
batman begins to change the genre right
and then the dark knight the dark knight
that's the one that it really became a
thing where like if you're an a-list
celebrity you want to be in one of these
movies because you have a chance to win
an oscar you have a chance to really
have some meaty
material to make you go and so of course
dark knight rises i mean i'm sorry the
dark knight
absolutely fabulous movie i thought
it kind of went off the rails a little
bit but i believe that's because the
dude died i think heath ledger died uh i
believe he died even in the making of
the movie like or like
where they st they needed to do pickups
or something i just think that they
changed the movie because of his death
i don't know if that's true or not i i
believe that that's because i believe it
was like too long and they had like a
third act about two-faced that i thought
i i didn't really
i didn't like that i i
the the second the third act of that
movie is where it kind of went off the
rails but the joker was now played in a
way that you were like ooh this guy is
like a really dark menacing character
and i wish that movie was rated r then
we really could have saw something but
he was already like you know why so
serious you know what i mean he was such
a good he did heath ledger did such a
good performance that i think that you
know the dark place he had to go to in
his soul i think it overwhelmed him i
mean acting's not a i'm telling you
something right now acting is not a
natural thing to have to tap into
emotions
you feel those things man and sometimes
when you're playing something like that
i mean sometimes it has an effect i'm
sure so but he really did a great job in
that and once again we're looking at
this movie in a completely different way
and then after dark knight rises you
have then there's dark knight rises when
you had bane
and you know just the way that movie the
trailer for that movie and you had like
you know the you know this really
menacing character with a lot of subplot
and a lot of like this is what happened
this is how it happened and you know the
league of shadows and all this stuff and
but like i wasn't a fan of that movie
like to me it's like that wasn't my
favorite movie at all um
uh
it just i didn't believe it like i'm
like no they wouldn't let gotham city
get taken over like this even though
that's a theme in the batman comics a
lot a theme in the batman comics is
uh you know the gotham always gets cut
cut off from the rest of the world and
they have to
uh
do this they have to um
you know
they're they're on their own and
batman's there to like make sure that
the the crime doesn't take over you know
that that's just a theme throughout the
batman series so that's they were trying
to do with that it just didn't seem
believable to me
so i just you know went off the rails
and then baine's voice and batman's
voice it was like a battle of weird
voices so it kind of like it went to a
place but it was still it was still an
entertaining movie great movie but
you know they were trying to compete
with marvel at the time i think that
they started to see this marvel thing
the mcu universe start to unfold and
they were like man we're behind you know
they're making all these great movies
over at marvel even if the movies
weren't great they were leading to
something that we know what it turned
into is this avengers and end game and
infinity war and all this stuff so you
know it just turned into something
really great and i think dc was like we
should try to do that but i think they
made a mistake
to me they should have kept christian
bale as batman
okay just to have the continuity
because that's the thing about marvel
that is amazing they kept these people
for 10 years so in our minds we got
connected to them and they were this
it's not like they changed iron man five
times then you just kind of like you get
scrambled in your brain and you're like
okay well who's iron man you know so
that's the same thing they did with
batman so i think they should have kept
christian bale
um
but then in 2016
they did batman
vs
superman wait i missed a movie wasn't
there one before that wasn't there
i thought there was a
i thought there was a batman before oh
yes that's right that's right so it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so now
we're introduced to
um
homeboy ben affleck as batman
and once again batman vs superman dawn
of justice
i don't know superman's a tough
character to do because it's like when
you have this sort of godlike figure
where is there to go who is his enemy
that's why they had to have kryptonite
or it would just be ridiculous right so
they you know i feel like i think ben
affleck did a great job as batman we
never got to see a standalone movie of
ben affleck as batman but i thought he
was one of the better batmans but i'm
going to get into that okay i'ma get
into that and then you had batman and
suicide squad which was like whatever
and then you had the justice league
movie that's their attempt at doing the
avengers
you know
and then from there they had the justice
league like you know the the schneider
cut of the justice league
and then you have the joker movie the
standalone joker movie and then you
don't really get to see batman you just
see a young bruce wayne
and then now we have the batman starring
um what's his face
uh
robert patterson okay
so
there you have that
so let's talk about now
let's talk about now my favorite
batman's
okay so let's make a distinction here
you have batman
and then you have bruce wayne
so sometimes a the actor
was a better batman than he was a bruce
wayne
and sometimes you know he was a better
bruce wayne than batman you know what i
mean
so if we go down the line
um let's do that right let me mark this
so i know
maybe put a stream marker
that this is now
i think the best batman's who do i think
are the best batman's all right
i feel like ben affleck
was the best batman this is just me
ben affleck was the best batman on
screen
that fight in superman
batman vs superman
not the fight versus them okay which was
still pretty dope right
him batman is you know he's clearly a
better fighter than superman but
superman's just [ __ ] super strong but
you know the whole kryptonite thing no
the best batman scene ever on film to me
is ben affleck as batman rescuing martha
kent
now if you play the video game
that was a homage to the video game man
he hit the disrupters he hit the
grappling hook he you know he just
everything in that fight it was brutal
it was like he got hurt he got stabbed
he was you know you really saw like who
batman is in that moment and what he's
capable of right i have problems with
how they
you know batman don't kill people so he
killed people in that movie and they
didn't justify it enough for me but that
fight was just so brutal like that was
the best version of batman on on screen
man so i think ben as batman i think ben
affleck was the absolute best batman of
them of them all okay and then i think
you got to go with christian bale
because of
being in the movie that changed the
genre i thought that he was a great
batman i thought that like they had
different fight styles throughout the
movies and you saw him adapting to these
different like brutal fight styles and
you know like um i just
i i believed christian bale so i think
he was a great batman i think that was a
really great uh a great batman and then
you know not my favorite batman
but like
because i have i never liked
i never liked um what's his name michael
keaton when i heard that michael keaton
was becoming batman
i wasn't into it because i was like
that's beetlejuice
and i just couldn't see beetlejuice
being batman you know what i mean and
he's a comic you know he was a funny guy
and i was like batman's not funny you
know but i thought he was a good batman
you know
and again it was the first movie on
screen real
like
uh um modern era
batman so i'll give it to michael keaton
um
as batman and then i thought uh after
that
is that for my top five
uh and then my top five i guess
i don't know man it's tough oh i would
give it to uh robert patterson as batman
i think that's my top five batman's i
think this the batman i think patterson
as batman was pretty dope okay so first
batman uh number one on the list i think
is ben affleck number two is christian
bale number three is michael keaton
number four um who did i say number four
is um
um
that say val kilmer i think val kimmer
was a good batman and um
robert patterson i think that he was
i think he was that those were the best
batman's i thought
okay
best batman's
now let's talk about
bruce wayne now see this is the thing
there's a distinction like what's a good
bruce wayne like who really portrayed
this like billionaire
like in a way that you go like oh like
this is sort of an aloof guy that has to
like you know hide this secret identity
who did bruce wayne pretty good like
what's your favorite bruce wayne and
i'll say
i didn't like robert patterson as bruce
wayne but i'll get into the movie later
we're not gonna spoil i'm gonna the
spoilers will come later for the movie
uh for right now we're just talking
about batman so like what was my
favorite bruce wayne that ass tough
right
that's it's tough to look back and see
the
good bruce wayne's like was ben affleck
i think ben affleck is the best batman
bruce wayne combination i think he had
the best
combination of that
uh his batman was better than his bruce
wayne but i think the bruce wayne was
still up there probably two or three on
my list so i think he overall is the
best batman but who was the best bruce
wayne you know i gotta go i really liked
val kilmer as bruce wayne i think he
really if you guys can remember back to
that movie i think uh
that was you know in the movie i'm just
talking about the movies like you know
not the cartoons and stuff but like i
think val kilmer was a pretty dope bruce
wayne
uh even though that movie was trash
i liked what val kilmer was doing so but
i don't know if he should be number one
on the list you know
um i liked christian bale like somebody
in the chat said christian bill and i i
i might have to go with that too i mean
i think that what he really showed this
like
tortured soul he really showed like what
it meant to be bruce wayne
and like you know like like when he's
using himself as bruce wayne to uh
you know aid the batman you know aid
this persona like let me find criminals
as bruce wayne let me find you know so i
think that he did a good job as bruce
wayne but i just felt like it kind of
went off the rails in the later movies
and then he just sort of vanishes you
know what i mean uh so i don't know but
i think um he's he's up there i i think
uh
i think george clooney was a good bruce
wayne and it's just because george
cooney's cool he's a cool [ __ ]
man like george clooney got that thing i
don't think he was a good batman like i
wouldn't look at him as batman you know
what i mean because [ __ ] george
clooney he i felt like he was old then
uh but it just he was he's a cool dude
uh
but
like again the movie wasn't good but i'm
just saying who portrayed bruce wayne
the best okay so i guess i gotta go with
um
i gotta go with uh i still like ben
affleck i think ben affleck's bruce
wayne was pretty good he just didn't get
a chance to be in his own movie so
that's why we'll go with christian bale
number one we'll go christian bell
number one as bruce wayne will go ben
affleck is number two as bruce wayne i
think val kilmer was a great bruce wayne
number three
um oh man who's my fourth uh i think
number four bruce wayne
you know i liked adam west man
you know yeah some of y'all too young to
even remember that but adam west was a
pretty dope bruce wayne you know still a
cool dude suave you know what i mean
that old school acting so i kind of like
uh adam west as bruce wayne and then val
kilmer you know
val kilmer um
uh he yeah i like it's just something
about val kimmer's acting man i just i
enjoy val kilmer maybe that's just me so
you know so i really enjoyed those
those are my
top bruce wayne's guys those are the
good bruce waynes
all right guys before we continue let's
go into paying some bills man doordash
y'all
doordash look if you've used i've used
the doordash i love doordash because you
can also get groceries and you can also
get those kind of your favorite
restaurants that you don't normally see
on some of the other apps it's just
that's just the guide honest truth about
it you know if you need to run errands
and you're running chores and you're
running late and you you know you don't
feel like cooking you know you know you
know you didn't feel like going out
someplace doordash is the spot for you
man
um
or like sometimes like what i like about
the grocery thing is like sometimes you
like you go to the grocery store
and then you go oh man i forgot like
these three things that you really want
who wants to go back you hit up door
dash boom they do that for you the stuff
arise
you know
if you're like
if you're like hungry for something like
some kind of snacky thing late at night
they you know they got those kind of
places on there too rachel i always talk
about how rachel and i love to get
donuts late we shouldn't i'm working out
but sometimes you need a little sweet
sweet and doordash is the spot for you
guys along with restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash
get drinks snacks and other household
items in under an hour with over 300 000
partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle cheesecake factory and
those kinds of things ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely
outside your door when you choose
contactless delivery for a limited time
our listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code griffin that's 25 off
up to 10 value and zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code griffin don't forget that's code
griffin for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change terms apply
terms apply
also guys
today's sponsors are helix sleep
[Music]
let me just say something right now i
have a
bad lower back and i'm a side sleeper
helix sleep is the best mattress i've
ever had because like i and also i i've
been on so many different mattresses
traveling on the road it sucks so
it's just like i i've slept on some
really terrible mattresses and i can't
wait to get home now healing sleep has
like a quiz that you take it's like a
two-minute quiz you complete it it
matches it to your body type and sleep
preference and they send you the
mattress that's best for you you know
it's like e-harmony for freaking your
mattress or tinder you know what i mean
everybody's unique and helix knows this
so there's seven different mattress
models
soft medium firm like i say if you're a
big person they have a mattress that's
perfect for you for that i got the side
sleeve one sort of medium pressure i
love it a lot so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress and and it's matched to you and
the mattress comes right to your door
ship for free you don't ever need to go
to the mattress store again helix is
awesome but hey guys don't take my word
for it in 2020 they were the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine go to
helixsleep.com griffin take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
griffin
okay
all right where are we now um all right
so we talked about the favorite batman's
we talked about our favorite bruce
wayne's
um
um i don't know like so what are the
best villains i was i'm i was trying to
think like what are the best
on-screen
batman villains guys
um i haven't spoiled anything yet guys
relax if you're looking the spoilers are
coming a little later about 10 minutes
i'm gonna start talking about the batman
but i think my best what are the best
villains um of all time you know you
think you think heath ledger in terms of
batman i thought he did a really great
job again he changed the the that too
like what his performance made it like
where you were like oh wow you could
really go for it in a batman movie so
i really enjoyed heath ledger as joker
now this dude that played
um uh
the the riddler in this movie let me let
me get this guy's name let me get this
guy's name y'all what's it say paul dano
that's his name that's the riddler
he did the damn thing y'all he was good
i thought he was really good as the
riddler
um
so yeah i think heath ledger this guy
danno was good as the riddler i thought
um jack nicholson as the joker in the
beginning that first movie it was a
little corny the movie was like a little
they were trying to figure out but i
thought jack nicholson did a really good
job as the joker in that movie if you
remember back
so that was a pretty good performance as
the joker
i thought bane was pretty dope you know
what i mean uh what's what's the guy
that played bain
um
uh what's his name he's he's also venom
right uh why am i forgetting his name
come on uh chat help me out uh as we're
talking about it so yeah so i think uh
um
[Music]
yeah like
man it's it's
there's so many villains i think all the
campy villains from the first four
movies
yeah
i i can't i can't go with them
you know what i mean
like i can't go with uh those because it
was just so campy man
it was just so campy
but tom hardy thank you tom hardy i
thought other than like the movie was
too long and bane's voice like mr rig
i mean other than like that voice it was
kind of getting annoying he was still a
great character you know so i think bain
heath ledger
obviously um um
joaquin phoenix as the joker even though
it wasn't necessarily a batman movie but
that was a great origin story for joker
that was a great origin story for joker
so he was a great villain like i said
paul dano as the riddler was fantastic
i don't know you know i you know i
thought that
uh what's her name catwoman and you know
from the campy ones
from the campy batman's i thought that
uh what's what's-her-face as catwoman
was uh pretty good what's her name who
played cat michelle pfeiffer i thought
michelle pfeiffer was actually a pretty
good catwoman i thought she was like it
wasn't as like
nonsensical as some of the other
characters uh
but
yeah
i i thought i thought she was she was
good too so those are some of the best
batman villains
that we've seen right what do you guys
think of those batman villains
uh i didn't like mr freeze i i didn't
know i didn't like that
uh the what you call it and even because
even in the good batman's the batman
begins and knows
like i didn't like
scarecrow i didn't like the guy that
played scarecrow i didn't like that
villain i don't i don't think that
villain was very good
uh but
you know
because to me scarecrow is one of the
batman's greatest foes and i don't think
they've gotten that one right they
haven't got that that right i think
scarecrow should be an older guy i don't
know
that that was uh i wasn't a super fan of
uh that
character
and the new catwoman
i i don't i didn't count her as a
villain i didn't she didn't really come
across as a villain like a batman
villain and even what's her name anne
hathaway
they weren't necessarily villains they
you know i really wish they would have
made them villains like
give them like a dark purpose and so we
can really like root against them it's
hard to root against you know oh they
give them this like they're giving this
like fantastical sob story that we have
to go well i can't root against her look
what happened to her type of thing you
know that's why she became catwoman type
of thing right and then of course holly
berry that was all those movies were
trash i didn't like i didn't like her as
catwoman um but you know so those are
pretty much to me my top
uh batman villains on screen
oh by the way and then
by the way listen this is just my
opinion but i liked um what's his name
from suicide squad joker uh what what's
what oh my god why am i forgetting his
name man what was homeboy's name in
suicide squad
playing the joker um
what's his name guys
i didn't like uma uma yeah i didn't like
uma thomas uma thurman
i didn't like her
batman i didn't like her poison ivy
either it was too you know it just was
too campy man
too campy
uh but jared leto that's his name
jared leto
i like jared leto's
joker but i'll tell you when i like
jared leto's joker the best it was in
the snyder cut of the justice league
snyder cut of the justice league the end
scene where he's being you know he's the
joker and they're like you know they're
fighting against superman and him and
batman are having this conversation
man
that's how i wanted him to play the
joker throughout the suicide squad but
you know when you got like heath ledger
playing the joker and he wins an oscar
everybody that plays the joker after
that is kind of like whoa big shoes to
fill so i thought he was a little over
the top in the suicide squad but it's
the freaking joker the joker's over the
top
um
you know and jared leto is like one of
those sort of like like really out there
actors but i thought that the he really
the understated performance he had in
that last scene to me made him a really
good joker man i enjoy i enjoyed him at
joker and i hope he comes back as joker
but you know
like
one thing that the dc universe has done
that we have to wrap our brains around
is they have scrapped their
mcu version like they're not doing it
anymore so batman wonder woman
aquaman all these people i don't know if
they're connected anymore
or whoever the batman's gonna be
with them it's not gonna be this batman
or this joker you know what i mean the
from the the standalone movies
you know it's just not gonna be that so
those are my uh favorite like i said
those are my favorite villains i know if
you guys guys and obviously to get in
the chat like not just chat but on the
comments tell me your favorite movies
tell me you're of the batman's tell me
your favorite villains tell me your
favorite bruce wayne's let's get into a
discussion on the comments i love that i
want to hear what you think are your
favorite you know and what are your
worst or your best you know so let me
know your list within the comments so we
can keep the discussion going all week
as this episode is going all right y'all
it's time i'm telling you right now
spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert if you don't want to hear me talk
about the new batman movie now is the
time to check out thank you for being
here but if you've watched it or you
don't care now is the time we are gonna
be talking about the batman
okay i'll tell you good and bad all the
things i liked all the things i hated
and what i thought they should have done
okay so first of all starring robert
patterson zoe kravitz paul dano colin
farrell as the penguin he was great too
by the way i almost want to put him in
as a villain but he it just wasn't
enough yet you know what i mean it
wasn't enough jeffrey wright as james
gordon
and
a little cameo barry cro what's his name
honeys name cohegan as the joker but
it's at the very end of the movie and
andy circus as
alfred i mean the cast is amazing john
tuturo
as carmine falcone he was actually a
great batman villain i thought he was
great as uh as the as the villain
all right so let's talk about the batman
my thoughts the batman first
too long
it was absolutely too long of a movie on
top of having to watch 25 30 minutes of
previews because they really trying to
get people to go back to the movies so
it was like a three and a half three
hours and 45 minute experience depending
on what theater you go to
it was too long
just absolutely too long of a movie
really enjoyed i enjoyed it
i didn't love it okay
it was great but i didn't love it all
right
robert patterson as batman so this movie
opens up like we already know the origin
story batman's parents have been killed
they don't even address it they address
it in an off-handed way like in the news
like you know this marks the anniversary
of the death of thomas wayne and martha
wayne you know they don't really go into
it because it's like enough is enough we
[ __ ] know how batman became batman
okay so this picks up though in a really
interesting place this is like
two years in
he's a young man still you know maybe
he's like 28 30 you know like he just
whatever he's gone through he's now
batman and he's only been doing it for
like two years and he's obviously linked
up with with this guy gordon who is
putting this bat signal in the sky and
they're using it to scare criminals this
is a sort of thing that's been
established in the city so the criminals
are still like at large but they're kind
of like yo there's a dude with a mask
beating people up so like y'all be leery
so they kind of established that it was
dark the movie was it was like a homage
to the theaters and it was very like you
know it reminded me of a graphic novel
the whole movie was like a graphic novel
in like maybe three colors in the whole
movie man there's a lot of grays and
blacks and a splash of red here and
there but it was dark it was menacing
and you know i love how it looked i love
how the the director shot the movie i i
enjoyed all the artsy fartsy parts about
the movie and i thought robert patterson
was a great batman
i didn't like him as bruce wayne but he
was a great batman
uh when you first introduced to batman
you know
it's a great scene you just hear the
metallic footsteps and the darkness and
then batman just comes out of the dark
when needs like gang is trying to like
you know this gang is trying to beat up
this dude and batman comes to like
rescue him and he beats the [ __ ] out of
this guy you know what i mean and and
then they and he's like and what i loved
about the fighting i just loved it was
he wasn't great
you know like he's in a suit and he's
like learning how to like you know and
so he's getting his ass he's getting
tapped up a little bit like jackie chan
that's what i love about jackie chan he
that he gets beat up and recovers this
batman was doing the same thing i i
enjoyed the fighting of that and this
sort of brooding batman you know so the
movie opens up where
you know
the riddler is now
uh
he's
he's killing people
who corrupt people in government
all right so so so this is the movie
where they're like it's a sort of a
detective story of
batman trying to figure out the what the
riddler is doing and why
who why they did this what's the origin
of him wanting to kill these people of
course the government's corrupt and
they're trying to find out who's corrupt
and why they're corrupt and carmel
falcone is you know he's the guy that's
you know behind it all and you have to
figure out this unraveling story
okay
again spoiler alert i already told you
earlier so if you don't want to hear
this part you can leave so all right so
here's the thing they were trying to
show in this movie and i'm gonna tell
you now again i enjoyed the movie but it
was too long
they were trying to show us that batman
was this great detective
and if you know the comic books
that is the thing about batman the dude
is like sherlock holmes man he figures
[ __ ] out
and they were trying to tell us sell us
on the point that this batman is a great
detective you know what
he wasn't
that's what i didn't like about this
movie he wasn't a great detective he
actually didn't figure out [ __ ]
the riddler led him the whole way
alfred helped him with the cipher like
he wasn't a great detective a great
detective would like be ahead of the
game or figure things out
he figured everything out
when the riddler wanted him to figure it
out
it was too late
he didn't stop the bomb that blew up
alfred that was supposed to be bruce
wayne he didn't stop the the bombs he
didn't figure that out till it was too
late like when it was all said and done
batman wasn't a great detective so to me
they didn't show that they didn't show
that the way they
said they were going to like i say i
didn't think batman was that good of a
detective you know he
but even those riddles like yes i see
someone in the chat he found out the
riddles right but that's what the
riddler wanted him to do the riddler
knew he would figure out these riddles
and it led him to the next spot he
didn't stop any murderers he didn't stop
the murders he didn't figure out who was
in charge remember he said bring him
into the light he actually should have
figured out that bringing him to the
light was going to be the dude killing
uh
killing the guy he didn't figure out
anything you understand i'm saying like
as a detective he didn't stop any crimes
so
i felt like and even the riddler said it
at the end of the movie he was like oh
you're not as smart as i thought you
were you know what i mean and i thought
yeah he isn't you know what i'm saying
so that part of it i did not like now
let me tell you
if it was only a two hour movie now this
is what i think they should have done
okay this is what i would have done
this bruce wayne doesn't care about his
company
alfred's telling him yo the accountants
are coming he's like i don't care about
that i don't care about the money
he's just caring about like
the legacy of his father who he thought
was a great man and he's trying to like
change he's trying to do what his father
wanted help the city
on his father's death his father left
this
endowment to the city of a billion
dollars to help the city the criminals
because there was no oversight
have taken over this fund and that was
part of the conspiracy the reason why
so many bad stuff has happened because
they
they basically implied that they stole
the money and they misappropriated it to
you know for bribes and for bad people
you know and so
so bruce wayne has now
he's he's not taking care of his company
alfred's sort of doing it and like the
accountants are coming and people can't
get a hold of him and you know all right
so
cut to bruce wayne now finds out the
truth
spoiler his father wasn't the greatest
person his father made a huge mistake
and it cost him his life
so now bruce wayne is shaking with this
news that his father had did something
bad and it and then because of that all
this stuff was happening here's why i
feel like they made a mistake
that should have been his motivation
moving forward to be a better batman
because it was because
he
wasn't running the company
that that billion dollars got
misappropriated they should have made it
that he figured out that oh [ __ ]
i've been i haven't been bruce wayne the
way i should have been it should have
been that he found out that his lacking
of being bruce wayne is the reason why
the city is the way it is he he then
would have taken more responsibility
which would have been motivation for him
to be a better batman too you understand
what i'm saying like they dropped the
ball there because
at that point of the movie it became
nonsensical to me in terms of like i
didn't believe the things that were
happening because they didn't show
enough of it you know the riddler set up
bombs and it flooded the city and like
they didn't really show that
so you could get a sense of the gravity
of that you know
so again bruce wayne finds out that his
father did something terrible to you
know uh you know he found out something
his mother had a checkered past and his
father was trying to cover it up and he
he goes to carl
falcone and falcone murders the the guy
you know and then his father felt bad
about that obviously they didn't make
thomas wayne out to be just a criminal
but he did he made a terrible mistake
and he needed to pay for it and you know
uh he was gonna like come clean and then
falcone killed him that's what they
implied right
so that's you know
again i think they dropped the ball
of giving this bruce wayne some
motivation to now move forward and be
like yo you can't just let wayne
enterprise
you cannot not care about the money you
cannot not care about your company that
could actually make a bigger difference
to gotham than batman
you know what i mean like you're a
billionaire you could do a lot for the
city i never understood that you know so
it's like they could have shown that
um
you know what i mean and so that's where
i think they dropped the ball in the
story there
you know and i i say i wasn't a huge fan
of robert patterson as batman because i
was he was so
brooding and like it was like okay why
are you this way you know what i mean
like why why why can't you you know show
us more why he's this way because he's
so consumed with being batman i would
have liked to have seen more interaction
between alfred and him discussing like
yo man did you sign those checks
you know what i mean like
we're losing money or or that kind of
thing so he can re we can really see how
he's he thinks that he's gonna save the
planet save gotham by being batman when
he really could he could do just as good
much good as being bruce wayne
so i think that that was a muddled part
of the story
again it was too long and then so uh
what's her name chloe kravitz as
catwoman she's dope she's sexy you know
what i mean she's
you know
she's a badass but let me tell you one
thing i absolutely loved about this
batman
when batman and catwoman first meet up
of course she attacks him
and let me tell you something that they
did
they did this real
catwoman can't beat up batman
like there was no
oh like all of a sudden this woman is
stronger than the average man
i love that they did that
and it was a choice
and i i thought it made it it made it it
grounded it and made it more believable
and real
you know what i mean it made it real
like
batman was like okay you could chill out
okay you know he was like pep pat like
come on all right come on stop it you
know what i mean don't let me hurt you
you know what i mean it was like a real
like
that was realistic she can't beat up
batman
you know what i'm saying this 110 pound
chick ain't beating up batman
you know and they showed that and i
think that it also left it where like
you even her fights the way she was
fighting the guys
i i i felt
like it wasn't like a thing was like
well this is make believe they did it
good man i think that that was like that
attention to detail for it
was
pretty good but her story was just kind
of like
i was like all right so i'm not sure if
she was like obviously she was like
fluid with her sexuality because the
russian girl that got killed that was
her roommate was like you know they were
lovers i guess because she kept calling
her babe but what how you know who knows
they didn't really address it and it
doesn't matter you know what i mean
that's the thing too that i liked about
it too they didn't make a big deal they
didn't push some agenda down your throat
she just happened to be lovers with this
woman and it didn't matter and i enjoyed
that and she also liked batman you know
she gave him a kiss and was like yo you
know of course there would be an
attraction here's two people in an
outfit the dude's a badass you know you
don't know who he is you're like what's
up batman you know what i mean so
so that was cool
and but i i i think i thought she was
she was fine you know she was like a
fully fledged character you knew her
motivation you knew why she was doing
what she was doing and you know i i i
enjoyed that about it too
i feel like
were trying to push it
for her to be
evil or not evil but do bad things and
her mother they could have given her a
motivation to be bad i wish they would
have done that to put batman in this
predicament of like i understand why
she's doing this but i have to stop her
from doing this they didn't do that and
i wish they would have that would have
made it better too
i thought colin farrell was a great
penguin you don't even know it's him you
know what i mean uh you know but like
even his like subplot storyline to me
wasn't enough
i don't think they used him enough he
was great and they didn't use them
enough the batmobile was dope but she
only saw it one time but how they
revealed it was i think it was too late
in the movie to reveal the batmobile for
us to be like i think they wanted like
the crowd to be like whoa
batmobile but that [ __ ] was two
and a half hours in by the time we saw
the batmobile so at that point
everybody's tired
so
um
yeah just overall i thought it was
visually stunning i thought robert
patterson was a great batman uh she she
was a great catwoman i thought the movie
was good it was just was too long
and it i don't think the story was
strong enough in the end to to really
um
to really make you be wowed the dude
playing riddler paul dano did an
absolutely fabulous job he was it was
like seven it was like watching seven
you know
he just was like
i believed him and even when he was like
out of costume and having to be like
this like sort of crazed character
he only pushed it a little bit where you
were like ooh but i thought it was a
good performance you know like there's a
great moment where you think he knows
bruce wayne is batman and they did that
on purpose where you're just like oh man
is he no is it gigs up is he not gonna
stay but he didn't know bruce wayne was
batman and so
that like
kind of let you off the hook but
yeah so i thought
he was pretty good i thought batman was
pretty good i thought overall the movie
was great
and
i highly i recommend seeing it and i'm
probably gonna see it again
but you know you'll see for yourself too
so if you've seen batman you agree or
disagree with the things i'm saying make
sure you put that in the comments too
but guys i gotta go
um thank you for watching my all batman
episode remember too that i am uh on
patreon so i'm gonna do some more i'm
gonna do some more sports stuff this
week because the nba is doing good and i
want to talk about baseball a little
about that so if you want to see me on
um see more episodes please be a part of
my patreon that's that's patreon.com
eric griffin uh so make sure you guys
check that out i i have i'm having sound
issues so i can't do the music and stuff
like i normally do guys so sorry about
that
but i do appreciate you guys being here
thank you for subscribing thank you for
being here thank you for the support i
really appreciate that look for me on
genderjen look for me on king in the
sting and look for me on twitch uh make
sure you check me out on twitch eric
griffin gaming which i am there
uh most days i got to go do another
podcast right now but i will be on riff
um
twitch later today but anyways
thanks for being here i appreciate y'all
and i will see you next week
[Music]
thank you